no nel cesso no papà invece sono a papà
josè ragazzi web a vj oggi sono qua con
tecniche siamo di nuovo sul signor detti
jacob è molto bello uno fa il padre uno
fa il figlio e il padre di evitare che
il figlio si suicidi o un gioco
istruttivo
chi non vorrebbe che il proprio figlio
moltissimi messaggi ci siamo sono tutto
carico copriremo che quello che deve
uccidersi quello che deve poi che parte
subito
sono io il bambino mi sa sta nascendo
the nascendo mi hanno partorito in
questo istante forte è giusto che tanto
ti ammazzi subì mia madre sparita ok
questa chiave la prendo io intendo
assolutamente prova a entrare e vedere
se mi trovi giuro che sono ancora qua
dentro te lo giuro
stai scherzando lo giuro sulla gara qui
dentro ma non è di riguardato tutto
ancora suoi c'è il comodino cuori più di
turchi sono forti facendo mai preso che
auto dio sono libero a zero era rivolta
al condotto due livina lo stesso libro
sul libero salvami entrare nel condotto
papa sono entrato perché so che ti farei
niente di male vedere pieno di merda in
cucina comunque è perché c'è il cane in
casa in cucina che peccare ha preso a
trovarmi a ma all'amica stai facendo
no nel cesso no papà decesso no papà che
cos'è affanculo che volessero farceli no
chiuditi sono uscito a fare da qui
condotta di troppo ai andare nel conto
mondo grazie a io no ma come fai a
sapere due forse ha condotto da quanto
ci ha giocato sto gioco la smetti di
buttarmi nel senso e 8 in canna
c'è il sapone ho mangiato sapone
qualcuno così i rumori milanesi in
faccia per l'amor di dio con ansia il
corpo incredibile cosa cercandoli
qualcosa o no per mano mia assistita
vuoi smettere di sballottati dalla fasc
allarmi ha sì vabbè sono morto per ford
non ci arriverò mai fuori in tempo e
invece di sangue grazie papà sei tutto
bravo no sono morti sono morti in mano
un nuovo bellissimo ma 26 ora prova a
trovarlo mi troverai mai nella vita ti
do un indizio ma sono in un secchio a
xavi sta mangiando le pile le pile e
proverei fermarti credesse in india
vieni qua nova race mentre gianni papa
ho mangiato 12 pile è una merda se
facessi tra tritium nelle forme o miss
amica strada ai macro io mi nascondo qua
dentro il forno mica mi troverai mai
secondo te puoi uccidere il fatto io
possa uccidere te
secondo me no ha acceso i fornelli
pluviano abbassati accovacciati e fini
sta cucinando perfetta
che bello accovacciarsi in questo gioco
il cane mobile a un premio sarà buttato
sul tavolo della cucina macro e ne va
come ossia cagato anche in salotto
guardali ma dovete rumore e in cucina
far casini sono convinto sono morto
perché ho saltato su un cestino e che
come sono morto è morto intossicazione a
è vero abbiamo mangiato le pile vabbè ci
sono a ma ho capito a destra torino
dovevo infilarti mi hai visto
vieni qua
finalmente bene anche a prenderti perché
si incastra giocare due anni miei amici
giocano sono grandi vai vai pure in
cucina
sai che ti schiaccio fame o fan papa ma
se ti sto schiacciando questo fa come fa
il portale damine a mangiare dammi da
mangiare da mina a mangiare danni da
mangiare ti giuro che se potessi
buttarti giù dalla finestra l'avrei
fatta mi fa dove stai andando perché non
entra sotto la poltrona ma perché troppo
vada troppo bassa non ce la fai smettila
di andare in giro ti uccido che il tiro
5 secondi di vantaggio 5 conto 12345
bassa ma come brutto bastardo
il club les sens sono più in qua dentro
dove sei
e uscito in un'altra stanza ma come fate
uscire anche ho visto mai si era accanto
a tema si è cercato ma come vedi niente
ma dove 626 mi faccio bagni 96 d'attis
ha trovato sei bagni la mia un indizio
trovato cinque secondi di vantaggio di
luce ma come fa eco cina in cucina poi
il bagno che in cucina
ma cosa fai
ma smettila di uscire ti esce l'acqua in
bocca
no noi sta prenderti non riesco a breve
se riuscite a farla li chiama è morto
male è il gioco della vita e il gioco
del bellissimo soggiorno a grove quante
denunce partner per questi wikia in tre
secondi siamo morti
se sento prendendo la forchetta e sto
cercando una presa della corrente con
trovando no no perchè l'ha fatto l'ho
fatto sono abbrustolito mia moglie via
tre di don uno di colore ma se non ero
perché sono abbrustolito mi fido
oddio mai passate di vedere il
televisore torna indietro cosa torna
indietro attimo nella stanza ti vedo
ma perché c'è una videocamera perché c'è
una ship perché le scimmie continua
cocchetto mad monkey va bene da quando
papa c'è un sacco di trofei ed a quando
li ho vinti a golf figliolo che ho usato
come pallina non c'è scritto corso per
c'è scritto in mass porn hector nava
sulle scale ma [ __ ] cui ho creduto sul
serio questa l'altro i lancieri stato
convincente verrà posto essere la parete
ma vinico asme nokwe fatta scendere
seconda in casa il dito della mamma ma
come il dito della mano piccola il culo
è il cane oddio i cani a cagato in
garage salis e le palle
vieni ma cos'è quella roba lì ma mica
sparma cosa spara ma cos'è un fucile
sul cile dove sei andato dove porta
questo caso della grata di settima
questo parte non partire con la macchina
sei un bambino smet milan mi son
dimenticato la fottutissima aspetta che
inserisca metta tipo dentro visto che mi
sta incastrando attesa c'è anche la
merda ecco prendi questo scopo ad uscire
e sai per quello che lo fate lo sia meno
te ne stai buono ma cosa fai se un po
che non aspetti di strisciare sotto la
macchina che è pieno di un giorno sotto
la macchina ma se il fucile più grosso
di te vedo il fucile che spunta dalla
ruota e di cose più grosso il fucile
fatto perché non mi prende l'istinto no
sei scemo scemo eh vabbè se veicoli fero
va bene ma pensa se tornerà la mamma ti
fa chiedere la vita ma c'è suscita nuova
sushi grazie ma come potrebbe anche il
pollo 10 match è stato preso l'arma era
toccato teamus in piscina ti butti in
piscina a stazione da di babar così
scemo cercare che cammina sull'acqua o
cosa ebbe i volumetti la di aprire qui
ma perché c'è il detersivo li metti la
si sta entrando nelle meno lo sento no
stai morendo gal e salvo a mio figlio mi
salvano ma se ho vinto perché alla fine
è finito il tempo prima che morisse c'è
un secondo esatto avrei finito del primo
vinto io non si sa come è stato
bellissimo e stata la partita più bella
della vita camerun bridge dato prova a
fare di angri del no ho capito cos'è sta
roba
ci dobbiamo ammazzare ma cos'è sarò ma
cos'è martello ma cos'è questa roba
tutta 3 ass
basta mi lontano ti devo schianta piogge
il martello le manette le manette è
stato maso ti leggo fermo che è la cosa
più trash che abbia mai chissà cos'è
questo è un marchietto la spada della
luce ti ho quasi schiacciato domenico
vinto io regolando sto volando fuori di
casa per mandarci sopra fratello di per
palacinema pari pari dispari bimbo tanto
io quanto è buttato è 12 dai vado io a
janò mi ha fatto gravissimo che sta
succedendo sono impazzito sono andò a
fuoco
ti prego dimmi berlo maria riguarda
diletta 26 guarda macro schema poi son
crei nate per molin secondo sono fermo
oddio mi ha lanciato una granata stanza
si avvelena è una cosa è successo sono
morto mi ha ucciso
l'accordo ragazzuoli è stato istruttivo
soprattutto perché la qualità di suo
gioco e il fatto che proprio il motivo a
bomba dall'ines ancora volatile sto
superando il cielo in questo momento io
ma cos'è ai ragazzi un gioco che non ha
senso di esistere però spero che video
vi sia piaciuto big likes per il bambino
che vola per stenti e inter la granata
fumogena finale niente ragazzi conclude
video stand è piaciuto così crociato
momento è un mi piace è capace di due
bambini in totale le iscrizioni cell
canali di state trovate l'altro episodio
e altri collaboration che vorrei ma non
posso chiudere io col telecomando ma è
chi diamine conti del comando ai disegni
pronto più o meno ci vediamo così avido
bella ragazzi